si ce n'était pas du port du masque ici
et là on pourrait croire l'épidémie
coronavirus bien au large aujourd'hui
mais sur les plages de dunkerque
on savoure ce retour du soleil du vent
chaud avec sursis ça fait du bien en
plus on a la chance qu'il fasse beau moi
personnellement j'aurais préféré que le
confinement se fasse plus tôt l'hiver au
moins les loups pour le week-end l'hiver
pour qu'on puisse profiter un peu plus
d'éclat du beau temps mais bon voilà
c'est comme ça un peu trop tard selon
lui mais dès vendredi
dunkerque et les agglomérations voisines
seront confinés la situation épidémique
et en particulier très inquiétante
alarmante même ici à dunkerque un
habitant sur 100 dans la ville tombe
malade
chaque semaine duco vide à dunkerque et
dans la communauté de communes des hauts
de flandre
depuis une semaine le taux de
contamination dépasse par quatre fois la
moyenne nationale
une situation alarmante mise en lumière
par cette vaste campagne de dépistage
les personnes viennent surtout pour se
réconforter d'une certaine manière quoi
ils ont pas envie de transmettre à un
aîné ils ont pas envie de transmettre
finalement quelqu'un de fragile ont pas
envie de transmettre à quelqu'un de
malade
téva novell inc a déjà contracté l'aco
vide mais il craint d'être de nouveau
contaminés chic on mettait une aiguille
de donc ceux dont le test antigénique et
positifs doivent ensuite subir un
deuxième test une pcr cette fois l'idée
ce n'est pas tant de confirmer le
diagnostic
mais plutôt de faire un séquençage pour
déterminer la souche de coronavirus dont
ils sont atteints
c'est sûr que je les points
c'est ce qui est arrivé à christine zèle
qui venait un peu pour la forme non vous
êtes positive et là le vue de l'examen
la défaite finale
ces variantes pas et j'avais rendez-vous
ce après midi pour chercher mes petits
enfants
excusez moi que j'ai pas vu depuis
longtemps et je me suis dit oh excusez
moi ça va je me suis dit on va quand
même passé un test et j'avais un peu mal
à la gorge c'est tout donc là je m'en
vais téléphoner pour dire ah bah c'est
râpé pour ce après midi mais c'est mieux
comme ça
si j'avais pas fait je serais allé à la
loi soit à la catastrophe
c'est un choc pour elle qui dit
respecter scrupuleusement les gestes
barrières et ne s'explique pas comment
elle attrapé la maladie au co c'est une
question que se posent souvent le
docteur hugues leroy qui dirige un des
grands réseaux de laboratoires dans le
nord de la france ce qu'il s'est en
revanche c'est que le variant angles s
est répandue ici à une vitesse sidérante
on a vu tout de suite une grosse
différence dans les différentes régions
du nord pas de calais avec la région
dunkerquoise qui sortait clairement du
lot où on se retrouvait avec à l'époque
une dizaine de jours ce n'est pas très
loin mais on peut déjà parler de
l'époque avec deux tiers des pcr positif
qui était lié aux variables et alors que
par exemple d'autres régions voisines
comme calais on était à une vingtaine de
pourcents
un soulagement pour stéphane novell inc
mais le reste de la france retient son
souffle dans au moins dix départements
la situation se dégrade au point où l'on
risque de devoir là aussi imposer un
confinement ici marie ève bédard
radio-canada dunkerque